Come to the second part on atheism. I do
agree that atheism is spreading and I
remember when I'd gone to South area in
2015 when I got the king fel award Jamal
imam called me to give a talk and they
chose the topic give a talk on does god
exist. Jamal imam according to me one of
the best Islamic universities in the
world. I sent my son to study there. I
considered better than city. Let's not
debate. I send him there and they asking
me to give a talk on does god exist
where I feel the situation of and then I
come to know in the Arab world there are
books on atheism which are translated
and sold more than the English world
atheism is spreading even in the Muslim
world.
So how do you apply this by the
prophetic method? There are many methods
of how to deal with atheism. Let me tell
you one method that is commonly used
by the westerners
but I've never used it as a d I know
about it. I studied it. I never used it.
This is the first time I'll be speaking
about it for a reason. The contingency
argument it was argument that was first
started in philosophy by plateau total
hundreds of years in BC. Then it was
propounded by Ali Bessina. Then Al
Gazali in the 11th century. Then we have
people like Thomas in the 13th century
and by Godfrey Lebny what we know today
of the contingency argument
that there should be a necessary being.
I know about it. I never used it in any
of my dawa that you should know. But
I'll just speak about it here and there.
I believe in the prophetic method number
one. I'll come to it why I don't speak
about it. and about the infinite regress
which is used by some of the western
dies but I don't use it because if I was
on the opposite part and if I have to be
a debater against that I would kill the
argument very easily if you're going to
prove about a necessary being
contingency theory means that if is
contingent there has to be a necessary
being who created this this bottle
someone create who created that it
cannot go for infinite there has to be a
necessary And we agree that logically
all this argument was spoken by Kazali
and all but these are all metaphysical
and philosophical not hardcore.
Therefore we should know about it as a
die but I don't use it as a trump card.
We should know it. We should be prepared
for it because if I'm on the opposite I
said okay there's a necessary being the
necessary being is the devil. What are
you going to do?
So my argument is to prove Allah not
necessary being. If the opponent says
the necessary being the devil, argument
is lost. Or if he says okay there is not
one necessary being there 10 necessary
beings that means you have to agree
there are 10 gods. What are you going to
do? So I as a D I use the prophetic
method which was asked to me the best
method of the Quran. You should have
knowledge of the contingency argument of
infinite regress. You should have as it
can be used as supplementary but not as
a core argument.
And that's the reason today there are so
many atheists. That doesn't prove
hardcore way. It talks about
metaphysical philosophical argument not
hardcore. The only way we can prove
hardcore and I given the talk when I
gave in Jamal imam and I repeated the
talk in Korea. It's available for more
than 3 hours. Does God exist? Number one
I'll do I will congratulate the atheist.
People wonder why Zakir congratulate an
atheist. The reason I congratulate The
is because he's thinking. Most of the
human beings they are Christian because
father is a Christian. He's a Hindu
because father is a Hindu. Most of the
Muslims are Muslim because father is a
Muslim. He's thinking okay my father
believes in God who can die. So I don't
believe in God. Oh my father believes in
a god who abduct someone's wife and he
[snorts] takes the help of another god.
So he says [clears throat] there's no
god. I congratulate him because he's
saying the first part of the Islamic
shahada
there is no god half my job is done
there is no god only thing I have to do
is the second part but Allah and Allah
which is easy half my job is done when
I'm speaking to a Christian first I have
to prove to him that Jesus is not God
peace be upon him then I have to prove
about Allah if I'm speaking to Hindu I
have to prove he's God half my job is
done. So first thing I do to exist is
congratulate him.
I agree with you there's no God except
Allah. Then rather than asking many
people have a fallacy who created this
mic and who created that who created
that ah
God created the atheist will ask who
created God
you're stuck. This is a philosophy used
by certain of the duas which I say don't
do it. Don't dig your own grave. At that
time you should know the contingency
argument that there has to be a
necessary being. But why you're putting
your foot in the mouth. What I do is I
ask him a simple question that if an
equipment is bought in front of you who
no one in the world has seen, I'm
talking to an atheist. If an equipment
is bought in front of you who no one in
the world has seen, who will be the
first person who will be able to tell
you the mechanism of that equipment? Can
you guess what answer the atheist can
give? Who is the first person to tell
you the mechanism of an object which no
one knows about? Who is the person?
Maker, creator, inventor, producer.
Don't grapple with the words. He will
tell you the creator or maker, inventor,
producer. Agree with him. Just keep that
word at the back of your mind. I agree
with you. The first person is the
creator or the inventor or the maker and
the second person will be the creator to
somebody else. None. Ask him how did our
universe come into existence? He will
tell you there was a primary nebula and
then there was a secondary separation.
There was a big bang which gave rise to
galaxies, the sun, the moon and the
earth we live in. When did you come to
know about this? It was in 1973 when a
couple of scientists got the award. They
got the Nobel Prize and they called it
the big bang. Ah 1973.
So about 53 years. Yeah. 53 years back.
I tell him you know my Quran 1400 years
ago
same thing is mentioned in the Quran
chapter 21 verse number 30.
Do not the unbelievers see that the
heavens and the earth were joined
together and we clothe them aunder? No.
You came to know 52 53 years back. My
Quran says 1400 years back. Who could
have mentioned it? Maybe it's a fluke.
Okay. No. Yes. Possible fluke.
Okay. Now, what is the shape of the
earth? It's a spherical. How did you
come to know
when someone traveled around the earth
in the 16th century?
How many years back? 400 years back
Quran says
in surah nazy 17 verse number 30 well
and thereafter we have made the earth
shape and there are various other verses
in the Quran proving the earth is
spherical rather it speaks it is
geospherical shape of the egg of an
ostrich
and we know the egg of an ostrich is not
like a round ball it is flattened from
the pole the exact shape of the earth
who could have mentioned this fluke
don't argue
I'll ask him the light of the moon is
its own light or reflected light. He
will say it's not his own light reflect
like when do we come to know he'll tell
yesterday. Yesterday in science means 50
years back 100 years back 200 years
back. But the Quran says in surah furan
chapter 25 verse number 61 that Allah
has placed the constellation in the
skies and placed siraj sun having a
light of its own the shams and
kamar the moon having n a reflected
light. The Quran says the light of the
sun is own light described as siraj
wahaj oya meaning own light lamb taunch
and the moonlight is described as n or
mun a borrowed light or reflected light.
So what you came to know yesterday in
science 100 years back 200 years back
300 years back my Quran says the
moonlight is reflected light
400 years back who would have said that.
So he will give a pause. Oh maybe your
prophet was very genius. Okay don't
argue. Continue.
We know the planets revolve. Does the
sun rotate? He said yes. When you came
to know when I was in school, I read in
1982 that the sun revolves but does not
rotate.
Now science tells us that the sun
rotates and takes about 25 days to
complete one rotation. What I did not
know in school Allah says in the Quran
in surah amyia chapter 20 33
It's Allah who has created the night and
the day the sun and the moon
each one traveling in orbit with its own
motion. Bahoon describe the motion of a
moving body. If on the floor it will
mean he's walking. If in the water it
will mean swimming for a celestial body
it is rotating. So what I did not know
in school
now in your school it is mentioned
because now the books have been revised.
So what I did not know 50 years back
Allah says in the Quran
the sun is rotating. Who could have
mentioned that? There'll be a big pause.
Don't wait for the answer. Continue.
Quran is not a book of signs. S C I E N
C E. It's a book of signs. S I G NS
ayats. There are more than 6,000 ayats.
Signs in the Quran. Out of which more
than a thousand speak about signs. I
just gave you example of three four you
can hear my talk on Quran modern science
I gave it last year in the pearless
convention after every sign who could
have mentioned this and I CAN GO ON AND
on the universe is expanding in surah
daria chapter 5:47 it talks about
physics atom zra that zar is not the
smallest thing which we did not know
until recently in surus 10:61 it talks
about biology that every living creature
is made from water. That is chapter
number 21 verse number 30.
We have created every living thing from
water. Will you not then believe every
animal made from water? Surah n 24:45.
Every human being is made from water.
Surah Furan 25:54. And it talks about
zoologology. Animals live in
communities. Surah Anam 6:38. It talks
about in the honey is the healing for
humankind. that the bees they have a
special methodology of communication in
surah chapter 16 verse number 6869 that
in the belly of the bees there is a
drink of varying colors in which there
is healing for humankind that honey has
healing powers in surah chapter 16:69
who could have mentioned this we did not
know that honey had healing powers had
says that talk about zoology talk about
embryology alaka talk about Go on and
on. Who could have mentioned this? The
answer which the atheists give first.
The creator, the producer, the maker,
the inventor. This creator, this
producer, this inventor we Muslims call
as Allah.
So with hardcore science, we are proving
logically the existence of Allah
subhanaa tala. There are various ways. I
will ask the atheist. You say there's no
god. What is the definition of god?
It's a logical point when I say there is
no God, I should know the definition of
God. If I say this is not a pen, I may
not know what is this but I should know
the definition of pen. If I don't know
the definition of pen, I cannot say this
is not a pen. So if you are telling
there is no god, can you define me what
is god? So the moment atheist says
there's no god, oh you know god who can
die, even I don't believe in such a god.
You know god who requires to eat food
even I don't believe in such a god.
So what is the definition of god? If you
deny something so in argument you should
use logic very important. Yes, you read
the book of Dawkins Martinism, he says
that if someone says that the kettle is
revolving around the earth, it is his
job to prove. Yes, but for you to say
kettle doesn't revolve, you should know
the definition of kettle. I agree with
you. It's not your job to prove that God
exists. But is your job to define what
is God? If you say God doesn't exist and
then when whatever definition he gives
we say the right definition is suras
chapter number 112 verse number 1 to4
says Allah and only Allah Allah the
absolute eternal
he begets not nor is he begotten
there's nothing like him so this is a
four-line definition given about Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala in the glorious
Quran if any individual agrees With this
four line definition, whoever you assume
to be God, we Muslims have got no
objection accepting that entity to be
God. And if you hear my talk on does God
exist, it has various different ways of
how to prove the existence of God. And
wall only with the Quran can you prove
the existence of Allah. Hardcore
existence. All the other philosophical
debates that we have can be argued upon.
So I tell the Muslims, use the Quran.
There is no better way than the Quran to
prove the existence of Allah. If you USE
ANY OTHER BOOK, you will fail. This is
the prophetic method. Use the prophetic
method. When wasallam inj
the Christian asked him who is Allah
prophet was shocked. Not that he didn't
know. How can you define Allah? It will
take us the is revealed. Say to Allah
say Allah one and only Allah Allah the
absolute eternal
he begets not know his begotten
and there's nothing like that.